but for us or in itself the object which
for self-consciousness is the negative
element has on its side returned into
itself just as on the other side
consciousness is done through this
reflection into itself the object has
become life what self-consciousness
distinguishes from itself is having
being also has in it insofar as it is
posited as being not merely the
character is sent certainty and
perception but it is being that is
reflected into itself and the object of
immediate desire is a living thing for
the in itself or the universal result of
the relation of the understanding to the
inwardness of things is the
distinguishing of what is not to be
distinguished or the unity of what is
distinguished but this unity is as we
have seen just as much its repulsion
from itself and this notion sunders
itself into the antithesis of
self-consciousness and life the former
is the unity for which the infinite
unity of the differences is the latter
however is only this unity itself so
that it is not this at the same time for
itself to the extent that that
consciousness is independent so to is
its object but only implicitly
self-consciousness which is simply for
itself and directly characterizes its
object as a negative element whereas
primarily desire will therefore on the
contrary learn through experience that
the object is independent
having brought in a very important
consideration of desire in the previous
paragraph now in paragraph 168 Hegel is
going to reintroduce a term that we saw
coming up in the preface where he was
sort of laying out as best he could at
that point in time as methodology that
term is going to be life now one thing
that that occurs to you as you're
reading through these passages at first
is well isn't self-consciousness exactly
the sort of thing that we'd want to
identify with life and say here's how it
is fundamentally different than the
objects that it's engaging with it's a
living thing
whereas perhaps we're looking at things
that themselves are not endowed with
life they don't have that dynamism they
don't have that capacity to self
transcend to respond to different
circumstances but instead Hegel is going
to be talking about self-consciousness
having a desire that desire is primarily
oriented towards life so that's trip
seemed a little strange at the start you
know why why is he talking about life is
something being sort of outside of
self-consciousness being its object
what's going on there so let's explore
this and let's see why that's happening
I think that you know as we're going
through it you can say implicitly
self-consciousness understands that in
itself is life and it's trying to grasp
other life in in the process so he goes
on he says the object is for us right or
in itself and being in itself being for
us those are two sides of the same thing
as we've seen particularly in perception
and force in the understanding now this
is playing itself out in terms of living
things and he says the object which for
self-consciousness is the negative
element has on its side returned into
itself returned into itself or it is
reflected into its
and he notes that okay that's going on
on this side of if we want to think
about this as a polarity he's going to
talk a little bit later about the notion
splitting into an opposition or an
antithesis right so there there's two
sides to it
there's reflection into itself happening
here a interior T to it something that
is not immediately apparent on the
surface and we know that
self-consciousness is marked in
particular by the fact that it is
relation to itself and relation to other
things in fact its relation to other
things is also taken up into this
relation to itself so we have this
reflection into itself on both sides
doesn't mean that it's exactly the same
process that's taking place there so he
goes on and he says through this
reflection into itself the object has
become life now that's worth pausing and
and considering again why should that
give us life why should that not give us
something like you know iteration or you
know these days we talk about fractals
and that's the same sort of thing which
you could observe say in crystals why
does it need to be life think about what
life actually means the next paragraph
by the way is going to explore this a
little bit more so we don't have to go
too deep into that what is it to be a
living thing let's even get away from
human beings or animals and just
consider plants and fungi and things
that don't have an awful lot going on in
terms of locomotion or perception I mean
you know plants perceive in a certain
way their environment so the fungi they
respond to it that's really what we want
to think about there is a responsiveness
to what is not it and also a direction
of itself from within itself this
reflection into itself can can be parsed
out in a number of different ways living
thing
do have a kind of interior t-that and
I'm living things like that like the
piece of chalk that I put in my pocket
or like this jacket for example a tool
like that the piece of truck is also a
tool but it's a little bit more you know
crude all right
then a jacket which is all these pockets
and and folds and things like that
these don't have what a living thing
does have if there is any reflection
into itself quoi object it's not on the
sort that we're talking about here a
dynamic reflection into itself so he
says what self-consciousness
distinguishes from itself
all right self-consciousness is here
what it distinguishes it from itself as
an object as having being as having a
kind of substantiality as having an
other 'no stew itself
what did when it distinguished from
itself is having being it also here also
has in it insofar as it's positive as
being not merely the character of sense
certainty and perception not just being
an object that we can take in and grasp
as object but something more this this
interior already this this relation to
itself he says being that is reflected
into itself so the object of immediate
desire remember we saw that
self-consciousness is as he says in
general desire hunger craving need it is
a media need for life not just for air
not just for life living things in so
far as they are consumed as sustenance
and that is turned into dead things
right
not just for shelter not just for these
sorts of things but conscious
self-consciousness insofar as it relates
itself to a world outside of itself
outside of the ambit of just what it is
that this interior T it has desire for
living things
now this desire might play itself out in
many different ways as we're going to
see
Hegel's you know hurtling down the
dialectical train it's going to turn
into desire for the other the other
being an other person but there's no
reason why we couldn't linger here and
think you know just just things like
running into you know a meadow and being
fascinated with all the things that are
going on in that meadow that curiosity
is in fact a mode of what Hegel here is
calling desire the the wish to go out
into things and experience them to be in
an environment to have your shoes off
and feel the grass under your feet that
is what he's calling here immediate
desire those are you know experience of
living things we could have other
experiences too that are desired so he
says the object of immediate desire is a
living thing it is something that has
life or is life no life the way I have
it here capitalized you know Big Al
there's a bit more to it than just a
living thing we're talking about
something that is going to differentiate
itself into almost an infinity of
differences but we're going to put that
off for a little bit later on so he says
the object of immediate desires a living
thing the in itself or the universal
result of the relation of the
understanding to the inwardness of
things is what's in there what's you
know these forces these laws the
inverted world would we want to get at
the guts of stuff we want to figure out
what's actually going on behind the mere
appearances now we're finding that that
has to do with living things in a way
the living thing is a better
representative of this this function
that we see going on throughout the
Hegelian system of a unity involving a
repulsion from itself
splitting itself into two moments self
uttering as we call it the self same
repelling itself the unlike at being
attracted life exhibits that much more
directly
than do nonliving things or nonliving
systems we can say so he says this is
the distinguishing of what is not to be
distinguished or the unity of what is
distinguished but this unity is just as
much its repulsion from itself so now we
get the notion this notion sunders
itself into the antithesis that's why
I've got this schema here the antithesis
or opposition on the one side
self-consciousness as aware of its own
independence maybe perhaps even its
alienation from the rest of things and
its objects the things that
self-consciousness or consciousness and
self-consciousness is going to be
engaged with the notion is split into
two along these lines so he says the
notion sunders itself into this
antithesis the former what is the former
self consciousness is here we go
for it is the unity for which the
infinite unity of the differences is so
some consciousness grasping life is
grasping the unity of these differences
the Infinity the self conscious thing if
it stops and takes stock can realize and
this is why we can experience a kind of
vertigo just how beyond our our capacity
to take it all in life really is this
teeming as you know James called it
moving buzzing confusion right that's a
very nice way to describe the profusion
that comes with the world of living
things so he says the the latter however
is only this unity of differences itself
so that it is not at the same time for
itself self consciousness is for itself
as well as in itself not fully developed
at this point the living thing over here
or life itself is in itself but it's not
yet for itself it's going to take self
conscious
somehow united with this reunited with
this to make it for itself so he says to
the extent that consciousness is
independent so to as its object but it's
object this is why I put a question mark
next to the independence its object ism
only implicitly independent right why is
it only implicitly independent because
it doesn't know itself as independent
the object of living thing that is not
self consciousness doesn't know itself
even as consciousness even though it is
conscious in some respect right so he
goes on he says self consciousness which
is simply for itself and directly
characterizes its object as a now
negative element is primarily desire and
therefore on the contrary it's gonna
learn through experience that the object
is independent
how will it learn that the object is
independent by desiring it and you might
say by desiring it in such a way that
when it experiences what it desires it
doesn't find full satisfaction of the
desire if it were able to take what it
desires and completely assimilate it to
itself and enjoy it you know in a
perfectly fulfilled state then the
object would have no independence
whatsoever life living things in a
certain way can be said to resist our
desire precisely because they have their
own desires their own motivations more
than do mere minerals or instruments
like this
the determination of life as it is
issued from the notion or the general
result with which we enter this sphere
is sufficient to characterize it without
having further to develop its nature its
sphere is completely determined in the
following moments essence is infinity as
the supersession of all distinctions the
pure movement of axial rotation itself
reposed being an absolutely Restless
infinity independence itself in which
the differences of the movement are
resolved the simple essence of time
which in this equality with itself has a
stable shape of space the differences
however are just as much present as
differences in this simple universal
medium for this universal flux has its
negative nature only in being the
supersession of them but it cannot
supersede the different moments as if
they do not have an enduring existence
it is this very flux as a self identical
independence which is is itself an
enduring existence in which therefore
they are present as distinct members and
parts existing on their own account
being no longer has the significance of
abstract being nor has their pure
essentiality the significance of
abstract universality on the contrary
their being is precisely that simple
fluid substance of pure movement within
itself the difference however qua
difference of these members with respect
to one another consists in general in no
other determinists than that of the
moments of infinity or of the pure
movement itself
since he's introduced this conception of
life as something that is an object for
self-consciousness and which has to be
developed further it's natural that in
the next paragraph 169 Hegel would try
to determine this a little bit more
closely to give us a conception exactly
what he means by life now he's not going
to go that far with it like you know I
say here just at this point in the study
or as he tells us the determination of
life as it's issued from the notion or
the general result which with which we
enter the sphere is sufficient to
characterize it without having further
to develop its nature so you know we're
gonna find its nature developed further
not only in the sections to come in this
this particular portion of the
phenomenology but also later on in the
reason section when we are turning to
living things and trying to make sense
of them now that said Hegel is going to
tell us something important about his
conception of life here the one that
he's working with in talking about life
is something for which
self-consciousness fields were is moved
by an immediate desire something which
is unified with self-consciousness in
the notion or in the concept that began
but which is also split occurred from
self-consciousness what is he going to
tell us he says if we want to think
about its essence its vision it is
infinity or when Emily hides not having
a limit not having an end not having a
final point to it a line that we can't
cross she doesn't mean by the way not
having a purpose it's not end in that
sense it's end as in reaching a terminus
he says essence is infinity as the
supersession of all differences now when
we use this term supersession sometimes
it's out haben you know it's the the
verbal nominative
sometimes it's out Haven which is a verb
itself sometimes in it's something a bit
more complex in this case it's alcohol
benzene right and what that means is
something like there's multiple ways of
cursing this the being in the condition
having been alcohol been having been
transcended of having been ruled in -
you know something greater a greater
unity of having been superseded it you
know in the Miller translation so the oh
hey bong is here that we have the being
the the condition of that design this
beating is going to take on an important
role in all of this because he's just
talked in the last paragraph of remember
with the two sides self-consciousness
and its object which was life or the
living thing self-consciousness has
being the living thing has beating as
well they are not just related to each
other as you might say
the you know determinations of the other
they are independent that was part of
what we were driving it here we're going
to talk about independence in another
way so we looked at it in this by
polarity and now we're looking at the
the living thing we're looking at one
side of the polarity and it breaks down
into independence which we might stay on
the top level and an independence on the
bottom level or an independence of whole
and an independence of parts neither
which is completely independent because
we're there to be the case then we would
have things that are totally
disconnected from each other where have
we seen this by the way think back
didn't we see something precisely like
this playing itself out in the
perception section when we're looking at
the thing in its qualities indeed we did
so the essence of life is a super
session of differences sounds very
abstract doesn't and and the schema that
we have
is going to be very abstract so we want
to actually think in terms of you know
some examples that we might be able to
wrap our heads around we'll do that in
just a moment but the difference is the
weren't just Sheeta the splitting apart
in what sense so he says there are there
are all these differentiated moments
right it calls them existing members and
each of them in Hannah's he's going to
tell us and enduring existence we might
be tempted because this is alcohol
benzine it's it's been superseded to say
that these differences they're not
really differences but Hazel's not
saying that here he's saying no they
really are differences but they are
differences because they are in a
particular medium and here he is it's
really interesting metaphor and this is
just a metaphor that I tried to capture
on the chalkboard he says it is the pure
movement of axial rotation axial
rotation is when you're turning out an
axis right in way axial rotation is a
perfect emblem for something that is
changing it is in process and yet it is
also remaining still because if I'm
rotating on my axis right I am changing
my position relative to everything else
in the room in a certain way I'm
changing my orientation but I'm not
actually changing my location I remain
at this same spot assuming I don't have
inner ear problems and wander off you
know as I'm doing it you know I said the
same thing for this piece of chalk I'm
rotating it right the piece of chalk is
indeed moving but it's moving in place
so it's different than moving this way
or this way like we do when we write on
the chalkboard you know we did an axial
rotation on the chalkboard we just make
a point if we want to make lines that
turn into words it can't just be axial
rotation so he says pure movement of
axial rotation itself repose being and
absolutely and I love this phrase
absolutely Restless literally unrest
ting infinity
independence itself that is what it
means to be independent again we see
this this relation of self an intensive
relation with this sort of interior tea
to it the thing that is what it is in
its change is you know the same thing
and it's also different I tried to
capture that here on the board with this
succession bottle space
he's talking about time and he says time
you know it is what we're dealing with
here but time sort of spatialized time
in in the mode of spaciality now think
about a living thing right think about
what it means to be life it means to be
at one state at one time and then to be
in another state at another time
differences are taking place I'm
breathing for example right I'm moving I
am changing and you know I remain the
same thing in the midst of those changes
and this is a deep metaphysical problem
at which point do I become something
different you know the processes by
which that works are very different are
much simpler you can say for this piece
of chalk than they are for an organic
living thing you know there's a greater
unity a greater intensity of unity to me
and to my body understood is a composite
of these differences of these these
these you know these parts these moments
these members that are connected
together spatially but also temporally
and provide a kind of unity there's a
greater unity there in me in a living
being than there is in this piece of
chalk so going from moment to moment to
moment the question then is what status
does each of these have do they only
have their meaning insofar as they are
part of this greater you know essence
this this infinity this life
that per doors Hegel is going to say yes
and no yes they insofar as their
differences he says their differences by
being in this this medium you notice I
have a couple different things down here
being part of a movement being part of a
medium or a you know something that they
can exist in being part of this
Universal fluidity Miller uses flux but
it's actually flew C kite so I think
that that fluidity translates is better
than just mere flux does which he is
going to say is a self supersession each
one of these were tempted to say only
has its meaning insofar as it's part of
the whole right they've been superseded
so they'd better just have their meeting
as part of the whole and that's what we
mean then by essence or its we might
even say it's beating its basil its way
in being Hegel says no each one of these
it is an existing member it has an
enduring existence abba stayin it being
there in place not quite the same thing
as design but it does have something
going for it there and if it didn't you
couldn't have the out healing you
couldn't have the super session of
something that doesn't really have any
weight behind it doesn't have any
ontological density we might say or
ontological dignity to use a word i've
used in other frameworks of things like
living beings living beings and a
greater ontological dignity than non
living beings rational beings have a
greater ontological dignity that means
that they have a greater structure to
them remember we're talking about self
consciousness here so he says these
differences are present as differences
in this simple universal medium and this
Universal flocks or fluidity has its
negative nature only in being the super
session of them but it cannot supersede
the different moments if they do not
have
during existence they says it is as very
flux as a self identical independence
which is itself an enduring existence in
which they are present as distinct
members and parts existing on their own
account so to the answer well which is
more real which is is primary Hegel will
say yeah both thereby stymie the person
who is demanding I wanted to either be
the unity itself or I want to be the
parts it's either the whole or the the
composit parts pick one or the other
handle will refuse that pick one or the
other you'll say look it has to be both
of them or you're not going to get life
the living thing here's another way of
putting it the living thing has to be
entirely what it is at every one of its
moments cual living thing in order to be
alive right if the cycle ends then when
you say of course we have a dead thing
that's going to change but it's going to
change not because of internal self
movement but because something else is
working on the forces of decay like you
know bacteria and you know animals
eating it and things like that so this
is very important the living thing as
living thing is constantly in a process
of transcending its self at any given
time that's part of what it means to be
living and yet it also means that it's
wholly living in so far as living thing
at every single one of these temporal
slices or moments that comprise its life
so he goes on he says this is very
important being no longer has the
significance of abstract being living
being is different than abstract being
nor has their pure essentially the
significance of abstract universality
this is what universality really looks
like for living things not in as an
exception from the world that's
otherwise now living but in as you might
say the pinnacle or at least the plateau
because we're gonna go higher yeah of
beings since on the contrary their being
is precisely that simple fluid substance
of pure movement within itself the
difference quad difference of these
members with respect to one another
consists in no other determinant as than
that of the moments of infinity or of
the pure movement itself that is worth a
little bit of commentary if we're
thinking about you know in just in terms
of life what is the meaning of each of
these moments what is the significance
of them what what can we connect up with
them the answer is in a certain respect
one that's not very satisfying it is we
might say just this life or living hey
okay so you know you ask well what's the
meaning of the Frog at this point in
time being a frog and then somebody says
well yeah it's got to be something more
than that and we can say well you know
reproduction and you know eating flies
and all that but no it's really just
what it is to be that living thing the
answer lies there and the lack not so
much of intelligibility but the lack of
significance the felt significance is
something that is not going to be
satisfactory to the hunger to the
bagheera to the desire that is
motivating self consciousness life qua
life as just life is not going to be
enough for self consciousness that's
where we're heading but it's enough to
actually have taken all of this in
because there's some pretty high-level
metaphysics that that Hegel is doing in
this section
you